the story that really blew my mind
because it's the opposite of my
childhood yeah your father says uh you
know it'd be really funny if you and
your friend
get on an airplane
and fly to new york you were in
cleveland
and he'd say and how old were you like
eleven and twelve eleven eleven and
twelve imagine you know
yeah so being eleven and twelve you you
and your friend actually did that you
went to the airport mm-hmm you kind of
said to this stewardess at that time
before 9 11 you go uh hey uh we just
want to go say goodbye to our sister
yeah she's on the plane and you guys are
dressed in tutus or something yeah we
had pink pink leotards and our hair and
buns because we figured if we hopping
the plane didn't work we would take a
ballet class yeah and then you get on
the plane and the plane takes off yeah
it was pretty empty and the stewardess
realizes she [ __ ] up but she's afraid
to report you because she'll get in
trouble yeah so she basically got you
some cocktail peanuts
and you guys fly to new york yeah this
is the most unbelievable story and you
spent the day hanging out you stole a
few t-shirts because dad told you to and
you're doing these horrible things
and then of course you can't get home
and you call your dad and he's pissed
he's like i don't want to pay for you
guys to fly back to cleveland um why
don't you guys figure it out like i mean
he was like he was excited that we did
it but he was like i'm not paying you
got to come well he tried to he was like
he was he couldn't be really mad because
he had it was his it was his idea but he
got he did get worried like oh my god oh
my god okay go to a hotel and i'll try
to get you a hotel room so he was
calling hotels and he was like mary and
i will drive and meet you so but no
hotels would take us so he was like all
right all right you got to come back
come back and he goes but you got to hop
on a plane home cause i don't want to
pay for the flight pack
but it's so funny but then it didn't
work on the way back because they were
too crowded and we kept getting busted
so then he put it on his credit card
he's a nut he was not this guy but he
was also so silly and fun howard like he
would make everything a game like he was
fun he was a frustrated performer writer
so right he would do silly stuff like if
we went into a candy store he would go
like stove first candy store in
cleveland molly let's pretend like i'm
blind and so i go okay so we would do
these little scenes where he'd go in and
like knock the chocolates over like is
this chocolate and undressing mannequins
and making taking their shirts off and
making the one mannequin cup the other
one's brass like silly
we thought it was funny